The joe rogan experience.
Okay.
Do they have a list of enhanced breath for a woman's MMA?
Um,
no.
That's,
I'll need to ask somebody.
This is,
this is too long of a Google search.
I need to call up a big John McCarthy or um,
yeah,
you can't,
can't kick the ball,
but you can grab it.
It's just weird.
Like you guys grab that black guys do what they call oil check excuse when oil
check is sometimes in the middle of the grappling.
The guy will literally have his fingers deep into guys asshole.
Just digging in there and you know,
it forces the guy to move,
forced to got to move in a way to get away from that grip.
And I don't see,
I don't think it's in,
I don't think it's illegal.
It's not,
I don't think it's illegal in wrestling either.
I wouldn't start making MMA butt plugs.
No,
that would just shove something deeper in your ass and you have to have like a
protection.
But what if you don't know a flat?
Well,
the problem is you need movement like you're to,
you're asking us to be able to move.
So anything that you do that would like protect your ass hole would be
restrictive.
It would be like,
it would restrict your ability to move left and right.
It would be a messenger boy.
Yeah.
It would mess with your athleticism to our oil checks.
Legal.
What if it's like,
like this though,
like if it's as a flat center.
Dot.
Bam.
No,
that's
things in your ass.
So I need to find out if this is all.
So what about,
well,
Nah,
I've got to go to the bathroom and here's that.
Here's the one where he's checked.
Yeah.
Dudes do this all the time.
Chris Tufts is NC.
So I was on camera and says,
oops,
wait.
He says,
oh look,
he even said something on the end of it.
Um,
one guy,
uh,
actually got a rape charge from a wrestling match.
Apparently.
What,
when was this?
17 year old Jerome hunt faces 21 counts of rape and attempted rape.
Each count carries with him up to 25 years in prison.
Hunt's lawyer,
Mike Butler crank claims that complaints came from fellow Parker wrestlers who
were simply victims of a legitimate wrestling move bottler.
Just file a motion to move the case of juvenile court on that court document.
He lays out a lot of information presented to the grand jury before they
indicted hunt on the rape charges while he's indicted on the rape charges.
Wow.
Former state champion wrestler,
Jerome Hunt's lawyer says that all but two of the incidents reported happened in
the Parker high school wrestling room before the practice during last year's
wrestling session.
Before practice.
Before practice rape.
Yeah.
It possibly came from a wrestling move called a but drag or skinning.
Okay.
Before practice,
what is that?
Dragging before practice,
it's not something illegal or not being taught.
It's being taught all over one accuser even testified to a grand jury.
I didn't take it as a sexual move.
I took it as him just messing around.
La Who?
Who charged then a prude.
Hmm.
This is interesting because that is the oil check is like a legitimate wrestling
move if that's what he's doing.
It's like people have been doing whether or not you think they should be able to
do that.
I don't think they should be able to do that.
But people have been doing that for a long time.
Like in actual legitimate wrestling,
like bill,
look up oil check wrestling,
find a video for oil check wrestling because that's something that guys have
done like for a long ass time.
I mean,
I would even say that's like gladiator days.
I'm sure they did that well.
It's not the most effective way to control a person.
So it's not like something that someone does for a long time or on a regular
basis.
It's just when you're in a wrestling match with someone,
what you're trying to do is win.
And if you spend time fingerings,
but you could've been doing other things that would actually get you to win the
match.
So it's not like something that comes up all the time.
Yeah,
I call that a Friday.
But,
um,
some people,
uh,
you know,
some people who don't know wrestling,
who found out that this guy's oil checking people and you know,
maybe being a dick about it.
Hey,
Johnny's oil check and people no,
fine.
Just what is this?
No,
no,
no.
Not checking the oil crisis.
Oil check,
image oil check,
wrestling,
checking.
Just listening to Google oil check wrestling.
Yeah.
I got some right here.
That was about it though.
I'm going to drag you so you ain't safe.
Yeah.
Yes.
He
totally legal.
See how he's doing this and the referee's not getting angry at him and no one's
going to jail.
See this is,
it is actually a legal wrestling move.
That guy putting his hands in.
That guy's an asshole.
Like that is totally legal.
Not only is it totally legal,
it's so common.
Who made this video?
Like who,
who is like,
you know what I'm going to do today?
Like I said,
it's common,
but it's not the most common thing.
Like wrestling is all about.
Yes,
it makes sense.
It's not the best way to control a guy all the time though.
So when it does come up,
guys do it,
but it's not like the only way to do it and it's not like if you,
if you concentrate on that when you should be doing something else,
you're going to lose the wrestling match.
So it's not,
he's,
what he's doing is using it as a whole.
He's literally trying to grapple by holding onto the guy like that.
He's not necessarily,
he might be sexual or you might also be trying to inflict pain and discomfort,
but it's been going on forever.
Oh those damn oil checkers.
So take this one kid and calm a rapist for that stuff.
But the other thing was then said Doris before practice.
That's a problem like that before practice that that disturbs me.
Like wait a minute,
wait minute,
wait a minute.
Like hours before practice,
like five minutes before practice where you're warming up like in the locker
room.
Like hey check this out.
You're going over techniques like what exact exact,
what exactly is going on and how many counts did say like was it just one
person?
I think they said like 40 Jesus.
Yeah,
it's 40 people.
40 40 churches while I'll read it again.
Well,
I shouldn't talk about this kid,
and by the way,
this was a several years ago,
2006 actually,
but I'm 21 counts.
Wow.
Yeah.
That if,
if you know,
I don't know what that kid did,
so I'm just talking out of my ass.
But if the kid did what's in those videos,
you better go watch those videos because there's videos of people doing that,
but drag or oil check forever.
It's been going on for as long as he's been wrestling.
It's just not the most effective thing to do always.
It's not in every match,
but shit,
it's pretty fucking common.
Yeah.
You know,
and then they put plugs.
That doesn't help,
dude.
Stupid idea.
It's just going to go deeper in and you bleed.
It's not going to stop the guy from holding onto it.
I get a little tail on the end.
Yeah,
it's got good idea.
Make it a decorative,
but pull that out and the guy gets embarrassing.
It's happened.
Comes out of a loud pop pop.
It's like,
sorry about that.
A tech could take that.
Yeah.
Hello.
This man.
Did I hear that?
Um,
Brock Lesnar's thinking about coming back to the UFC.
Yeah,
it's bullshit.
that's bullshit.
They,
there's one hype story when they were trying to hype it up because the WWE was
saying that Brock Lesnar was in Vegas and they may might've big announcement,
but it's really just a publicity move to talk about Brock Lesnar's wrestling
appearance.
So there was a little bit of hype on that.
Some guys tweeting me that the,
but drag just not go into the butthole.
Um,
yes it does,
sir.
Sometimes the,
but track does not go into that.
They're saying it's a,
there's a nerve back there pulling.
Yeah,
you're right.
But tell me the dude's don't sometimes put fingers in people's assholes.
Hey,
if I can for sure dude,
cause I've had it happen.
So shut your mouth.
If I had to tell me,
don't tell me that oil checks don't go in your asshole.
I've had it happen.
Sneaky,
creepy fingers.
Do's,
oil drag you under ground on a graph you're going to like,
just rub it like around,
you know it's,
there you go,
you go in.
It's not like,
oh,
I'm sorry.
There's different people.
Look at this.
This is a nice one right there.
That's like,
yeah,
that's
definitely that.
Those women,
is that Bobby Lee?
Yes.
It's a woman.
There's a woman.
There might be Felicia.
Oh,
I don't know who that is.
It might be my friend Felicia.
She's a Badass.
Grappler know is not right.
These are the,
uh,
that guy's an asshole.
Yeah.
That,
that's the oil wrestling that like Russian oil respill Turkish.
Turkish over Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Anybody who says it doesn't go in your asshole shut it.
He's clearly looking at that and just being like,
yeah,
you fucking,
well,
you know,
it doesn't always go in.
Sometimes it just hits the tank sometimes.
Uh,
it's just the guy that hurt that would hurt.
Got a good grip on the upper deck.
It doesn't actually get in the asshole.
He's just pulling the lid up,
pulling the lit up on the macaroni and cheese containers.
Just get the steam out.
Yeah,
just Tupperware in that motherfucker.
But sometimes it goes in the asshole.
There's a lot of fucking butthurt wrestling guys out there that are arguing with
me right now on Twitter.
We just showed you photos,
you fox,
you're in denial and there's a lot of guys who have had their assholes finger
who were like,
thank you Joe for speaking up.
This bullshit did even go.
It can't go in,
dude.
It's a trap.
My ass holes like a bank vault.
Nothing's getting.
Then you might be knocking on the door,
but you can knock on my door.
Does that mean you sleep in my house?
No,
it does not mean you sleep in my house.
You're just knocking on my door.
You can't get in.
I think it's time.
If you have had your butthole invaded by finger to come out and sows the brown
stuff,
fish of security,
nothing.
Nothing gets through.
It's tight.
It's like,
like that fucking went event horizon when,
when it opened up the time for favorite scary movie ever.
That's my favorite scary movie of all time.
I'm so glad you said that.
Fucking good,
scary,
terrifying movie.
Yeah.
The idea that they run into hell,
whoo.
Going through enough.
Brian,
he nef,
e.
N.
U.
F.
What are you showing more guys with hands up dude's ass holes.
I think we get it right.
It happens.
Wrestling fans.
I know you don't like to believe it happens,
but it happens.
Oh yeah,
that was real too.
It's all real.
That's different.
That's just two men standing their ground with their lips locked and trying to
gain an advantage.
Making Valentine's Day plan.
By the way,
that White Guy,
one white guy won that one as much to dismay if black people everywhere I should
have,
but check them much to dismay of Anderson Silva fans,
much to dismay of people don't like wrestling or Buczek's oil checks drags,
but tracks.
I'm sure Chris Weidman has been oil checked some time in his life.
Last name like Weidman is how you make an animal like that.
Why?
How dare you?
What is this a parody?
Can we play your parody video?
What is it?
It's called not looking.
Not Looking.
Yeah.
That's fake.
Brian Stout.
What?
Jesus find believes everything.
Twin Towers.
Fucking black helicopters.
That Shit's naked.
Okay.